okay good morning everyone it's 10:30
and we'll get on the way welcome to the
first cabinet meeting of 2020 first item
on the agenda apologies for absence
we have qualities from a councilor lvc
and councillor Busby okay thank you
declarations of interest by councillors
Castle Osborn Thank You mr. chairman
yeah I'd like to declare a non-pecuniary
in item eight as I'm a member of the CA
be thank you any others okay the next
item BCA 1924 to confirm the minutes of
the last meeting we had which was back
in November 7th in November just to go
through page 1 page 2 anyone and finally
page 3 all happy with the minutes yep
thank you
the next item to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
castle's petition scheme exciting
questions by councillors received and
matters referred by the overview of
scrutiny or joint order data standards
committees thank you moving on then the
next item is the forthcoming decisions
this which you will all have got copies
of does anyone have anything they wish
to to say about the items on this
everyone happy with the forthcoming
decisions of this okay thank you Rick
item then is paper BCA 1925 the
three-year funding for the sovereign
District Citizens Advice and I'd like to
ask councilor Davis to introduce this
please yeah baby has traditionally
helped to fund the CIB at sudbury and
also ellipse which last year at a
scrutiny meeting it was brought up that
it would help the CI bees you know and I
use the plural there paper and in other
areas to have a more certain financial
future and and the request has been made
for us to fund them guarantee funded for
three years at the moment we just do it
on an annual basis the the CA bees have
suffered some serious cuts from Summit
County Council which is the slack was
picked up a little bit by the Clinical
Commissioning group and and ourselves
but it's it's important for the the CA
bees to have this financial certainty
while they look at their own methods
moving forward in terms of perhaps
streamlining their services coming
together Suffolk County Council last
week approved actually not to cut the
whole amount but to give them a hundred
twenty thousand pounds and per year
which obviously helps them but we know
and I'm sure all members will be aware
of the valuable service that the CA be
provide for our residents in Baber and
further afield and whether those people
go to Sudbury oughta lips which it's a
vital service therefore I think the
three-year funding agreement for the
submarine district CA the Citizens
Advice should be approved and that the
authority be delegated to the assistant
director
communities to sign the agreement
following discussion with the cabinet
member for communities happy to take any
questions Thank You counselor does
anyone have any questions or any
anything they wish to say councillor
Osbourne I fully support this report and
I'd actually like to see a three-year
rolling review so that have guaranteed
beyond those three years so I'll be
making a recommendation to to add that
to the current recommendation and the CA
B they really do as councillor Davis has
just alluded to they play a real
critical role they're a critical partner
for the housing team who would find it
very difficult to manage without their
assistance and their support they're a
critical partner for the shared revenue
partnership which provide valuable data
plus day-to-day advice as well so I
fully support this and I would like to
see this report go through and
recommendation proved Thank You mr.
gentleman
Thank You Tommy I believe you wanted to
say something just just a point on the
the recommendation the recommendation
covered under 3.2 will allow for a
rolling agreement to be put in place so
the delegation to they with John we can
make that a rolling three-year agreement
does that need to be explicitly stated
in the recommendation then sorry because
it's delegated Tom whoever would have
that authority it's better to do that
and for example if if we wanted it to be
inflation-linked as well and that would
again would be delegated power for Tom
in discussion with the cabinet with
whoever's a cabinet member with that
portfolio at the time so it's included
in three points does anyone else have
anything
outs I'm late everybody um just in the
vision that the scrutiny committee task
and finish group met earlier this week
the scrutiny committee met yesterday you
will be getting an updated report it's a
bit later than you and it doesn't affect
this year's decision or anything that
you're talking about today but it will
be carrying along exactly the lines as
far as this council is concerned and mid
Suffolk is concerned suggesting the
rolling three-year funding arrangement
with provision for inflation pretty much
exactly the same point so you'll have
that for your next cabinet meeting but
it's not complete but it's only just
been agreed that you should get it if
you follow me that's all it was just I
thought you should know thank you very
much for the approach taken by this term
mid suffer councils in in the matter
these are bridges appreciated thank you
that's that's very helpful and I know
you you met yesterday afternoon wasn't
it and does anyone else have yeah um
don't question anyone's wording so far
about the valuable service they do
provide and going forward obviously want
to maintain that service I am just a
little bit wary of the commitment in
that I'd also like to see the CIB
increase their efforts to fund
themselves we're all experiencing
difficult times financially both the
county and the district and as much as
we're going to invest in this and it is
such a valuable service I think we do
need to see that they are doing all they
can to generate their own income and for
those rolling gears it is vitally
important we do see that in that they
don't just rely totally on the county
and the District Council's and almost
pull back from what they should be doing
I think it's important that we see some
sort of a business plan from them to
know what their plans are in that
respect and so long as this role in
project does come before the cabinet to
get their approval each year then I
don't really have a problem with it as
it is but I just want to see them come
to us to show us that they are doing all
they can to generate as much income as
they can yeah Thank You councillor I
think in addition to that that they need
to demonstrate that they are continually
making improvements in efficiencies and
and internal savings on the cost of
delivering the service Tom did you want
to come back yeah I just wanted to give
comfort and confidence I guess that the
funding agreement that goes to them will
require deliverables to be reported back
there will be a monitoring arrangement
so that we understand the impact that
they're having the way that they are
working and it's almost kind of business
as usual activity for the grants team to
continually work with and support all of
our all of the organizations that we
support financially to provide them with
funding advice to ensure that they are
as kind of up skilled as possible in
terms of generating their own income
that they are exploring all
opportunities to generate from national
funders from local funders with the
cia's enmity
one of the things that were seeking to
stimulate I know that separate Town
Council and Hadley town council make
contributions to the CAS well they I
think are seeking to approach all parish
councils because for example all it's
not just residents of Sudbury that get
advice from Sudbury CA its residents
across the board so they are continuing
to explore all opportunities for funding
and I know as part of the scrutiny
exercise there was a suggestion from
Suffolk County Council for example that
some of what they provide people would
be willing to pay for and therefore
should they put charging in the debate
that was had at the cross or thority
task and finish was that if you enter
the realms of creating the perception
that people have to pay for any of the
advice that they get from the CAS that
can be really harmful in terms of people
feeling it's an organization that they
can go to so there's some subtlety in
terms of what they need to do to
generate income because they need to
maintain a public perception that it's
kind of all advice is free at the point
of use type thing but they absolutely
need to continue to work on efficiencies
they need to look at what they are doing
cross county to look at their own
financial management for example how
they deliver payroll and some of those
back-office functions to see whether
they can merge those across cos across
the county and part of the county
councils funding commitment stimulates
that kind of activity the county had
perhaps gone a step further than others
would have liked to in terms of
encouraging that the county council
would like to see for cas across the
entire county that's not necessarily an
aspiration held by all of the individual
Citizens Advice and and again there's
kind of tension between the amount of
volunteer effort and support that they
get which is often very locally grounded
and being able to save costs so if you
had one see a across Weber and mid
Suffolk for example you might save costs
or managers that you might lose
volunteers because there wasn't that and
local ownership of the activity so again
there's just some subtlety in terms of
how they go about managing that but
absolutely ensuring that that they are
conscious not to become dependent and
rely or to to avoid as far as play
possibly can dependency on grant funding
from external organizations is something
that we will be driving them and it will
be part of the monitoring arrangement
that we put in place in terms of the
three-year role in agreement that they
report back annually and and have to
meet a set of kind of mutually agreed
outcomes thanks Don Cutler Davis totally
endorse Thomas head and he's explained
it very well and I think it's it is
important because we don't want to be
ticket people picking up the slack
others are letting go so it's important
that we do that but I think the
three-year funding actually helps the
CAS to plan further ahead and also to
make those cuts where and they can
knowing that they've got a little bit
more certainty from us and also points
out that we are the communities team is
are carrying out a grants and review for
all the grants as well not just the CAS
to make sure that the money we're given
is not just a you know a tick box
exercise it is because people actually
need it or deserve it or you know it's a
requirement that we need to do Peggy
Kasparov II yeah I'm not quite sure
about what Thomas said about funding
gumming forward beyond the three years
because I think he said that the
agreement will provide for delegated
authority to make that decision after
the three years is up that implies that
the agreement is some sort of formal
document rather than just us agreeing to
something and we of course haven't got
that agreement in front of us that
states that so I don't think that the
recommendations that we've got actually
cover for beyond three years at all
because the recommendations clearly
state that a three-year funding
be approved and that authority be
delegated for sign-off of that agreement
so I'm a little bit unclear about what
we're actually agreeing to this morning
are we agreeing I think from the
recommendation what we were agreeing to
is just simply three years funding and I
thought that the question that was asked
was you know can do we have a commitment
beyond that three years yeah the
question was is it a rolling three-year
and I can understand me I think we'd be
quite comfortable to tweak we'll add the
word rolling in the three-year because
as it says it is dedicated to it's a
term at the moment so if we were to
change it and say through it rolling
through year and then we could also add
in you know inflation links and
everything like that and it would just
get longer and longer and longer but at
the moment it's quite clear that it's
delegated to - - Tom so I mean if you if
you prefer that we put the word rolling
in I can't imagine that there'd be any
any objections to that whatsoever so
it's entirely you know I'm happy to
change to amend the recommendation to
say rolling through you if I can just be
clear the only reason I've brought it up
is because in the recommendation it says
that authority be delegated to Tom with
regard to sign off of this agreement and
this agreements at three point one is
three years so it doesn't appear clear
to me I mean I accept that tom has said
that it wouldn't actually be like that
it would be something different but if
it's gonna be something different that
ought to be what we agree the only thing
I would add to that his Michael made a
good point about us being able to review
it on an annual basis as well and so
this time next year we would say yeah
we're gonna carry on with the three-year
agreement so you know again and if we
put rolling and we probably wouldn't
need to bring it back in a year's time
because it would
before I make a comment Cotswolds one
you wanted to say something yeah I'm
just thinking surely the whole idea of
the three-year roll in review is to give
confidence to the CA B and members of
the public bearing in mind this document
is in the public domain
we need to give that assurance and I
think by just adding that one word
rolling into it I think we need to add
anymore we'll give that assurance to
both the C a B and to other counselors
and to members of the public okay if I
can if I can assist ya an amended
recommendation that a three-year rolling
funding the agreement for the submarine
District CIB approved would give that
clarity in terms of the actual agreement
we would still want annual reporting on
that basis so it does give that
confidence but equally it would be
remiss of the authority to simply grant
a three-year revenue and you know
without tracking that on a on a on a
regular basis which it actually will end
up in some kind of formal monitoring on
an annual basis but will probably result
in our grants officers are going to make
them quarterly to track how they're
getting on how spenders occur and all
those fun things in the same sort of way
that we do with other revenue funded
projects so adding adding the word
rolling into recommendation 3.1
absolutely gives transparency I guess in
terms of what that means thank you tom
cassell whole can I just be clear that
rolling
yes but the cabinet will be presented
with a presentation each year of an
update on where we are with the CIB with
their funding so it does come to cabinet
for discussion can I just have that
confirm that that will happen it's not
going to be delegated to the cabinet
member and yourself and we as a cabinet
won't be presented with that it will
just be signed off each year I just want
to make sure it comes back the cabinet
so they clean so the cabinet's a whole
can view what is actually happening
yeah yeah that is exactly how that will
be
and also as tom says it'll be monitored
on a quarterly basis
Tom so there's just a little bit teasing
apart there in terms of what you would
like cabinet to do so on the one hand I
think I'm hearing from John and others
and and in the room a sense of giving
confidence around a three year
arrangement giving them confidence going
forward if you're bringing it back to
cabinet to actually approve the funding
on an annual basis then it doesn't
necessarily give that greater confidence
if you would like to bring it back to
cabinet for an update or impact report
from the CA they're there two slightly
different things so if you want an
impact report from the CA on an annual
basis absolutely and we can do that
whether it's to cabinet or Council or an
all member briefing or or whatever or or
into scrutiny committee on an annual
basis absolutely I think that's a
something to be kind of applauded and
would give visibility if you're looking
for cabinet to make the decision on the
funding on an annual basis then you're
back to an annual sign-off process I
think scrutiny is the way for it to go
as you say I don't know II think as a
cabinet I'm just making I just want to
make sure that there's an authority we
have that presentation and that whether
it be scrutiny it's the right way for it
to go that they have that so that they
are sure and happy with everything is
going forward yes I think we all would
be happy with that
certainly there needs to be some some
formal reporting back and scrutiny does
seem to be the best mechanism for that
cattle McCraw would you comment you just
do add that in fact what tom has been
saying and what members have been saying
very closely allied to exactly what will
be you'll be getting as an updated
recommendation from the initially the
task and finish group which is courses
dealt with this through four separate
authorities and then from our own
scrutiny committee our recommendation to
you as a cabinet
and forever everybody as a council will
be that it be a rolling annual review
subject to consideration of inflation we
think that fits the bill in terms of the
needs that they annual review it's up to
you to decide where that should take
place and I can see no objection to it
to going through scrutiny that seems
perfectly reasonable by that time we
will have looked at the operations of CA
across the South fook-la well on a
regular basis already we've already got
the experience now amongst ourselves
Thank You castle crawl does anyone else
councillor off yeah I think scrutiny is
the the place for it to go I think that
it ought to be done every year after the
accounts are available I think it's
quite useful to be able to have a look
at the accounts here and I think we
ought to be encouraged by the fact that
great cornered parish counts or have
increased their contribution so of
sublet and council so of Hadley Town
Council and so have the other parish
councils that's actually quite
encouraging that a few hundred quid is
nearly a thousand pounds now because of
course the surrounding villages the
residents there all benefit as well so I
think it's really encouraging that
they're actually attracting
contributions from from sort of the the
wider community and not just relying on
us and the county council as far as the
amount of money that we're putting in is
concerned over the three years and
beyond we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of pounds so I think this
council should have some method by which
it scrutinizes the the activities so I
don't need propose it I don't think that
I mean at this time of year it ought to
go to to scrutiny just so they can have
a look at it so just going back to the
recommendation we are going to put in
there now or rolling the 3-year program
are we to make it absolutely clear that
it's three years and it rolls forward
yes that is I think everyone's desire
for that and of course if there are only
any specific issues that scrutiny
cabinet to to resolve as a result of
their annual River
that can be the mechanism they'll then
pass up through to us so they know no
more comments on this may have a
proposer for the amended recommendation
please councillor Davis second to Castle
Osborne all those in favor thank you
right moving on then the next item is
paper BCA 1926 the introduction of a
council tax penalties policy although
right that we offer castle tax discounts
for single residents and other
exemptions and reductions it is
essential that our information is
accurate and that we are informed by
residents as soon as they are no longer
eligible for this the shared revenues
partnership undertakes a review so that
we have up to date information and
canvas you pursue any shortfall in
council tax resulting from a change in
circumstances prompt notification of
changes to circumstances allows our
records to be updated so that we can
issue revised notices to taxpayers and a
timely issue of revised council tax
bills would also benefit the taxpayers
by spreading any increased payments over
along the period this will also have a
benefit in assisting with council tax
collections the notification conditions
are listed in paragraph 4.4 of the
report we are able to issue penalties in
cases where the taxpayer has failed to
notify us of a change but currently none
of the shared revenue partnership Pappas
does this the single discount review
costs up to 30,000 pounds effort for the
2018 to 2019 financial year the
additional council tax revenue obtained
by this was 69 thousand pounds the
possibility of updating a penalty of
sorry of applying a penalty may further
encourage customers to keep taxpayer
details up to date meaning that the text
base is as accurate as possible which in
turn could mean more council tax being
paid the penalty chargeable is 70 pounds
to the initial failure to notify rising
to 280 pounds for each subsequent
failure to respond to requests for
updated information it is estimated that
for 2018-19 we could have achieved an
additional revenue of fifteen thousand
nine hundred and
she pounds which is a this is in
paragraph 6.1 of a report on the basis
of the number of 75 finds we could have
imposed however I must stress that the
primary intention of this policy is for
penalties to be used as a as a deterrent
against fraud and error and not as a
regular source of income further
information is provided in the report
and it's Appendix A which contains the
actual penalties policy so I'd like to
propose the recommendations of paragraph
that 3.10 report that counsels approved
the implementation of a policy for the
issuing of council tax penalties and the
reason given that the council is
committed to a proactive approach in
preventing and reducing the risks
associated with fraud error and other
irregularities in the administration of
council tax implementation of this
policy supports this commitment may I
have a second councilor Osborne any
questions anyone Cussler Aarthi yeah
I've got a question about whether this
will cover the activity that I think
perhaps all of us encountered when we
were going around houses for last year's
election certainly in my ward I came
across it where people have two homes
they have a holiday home and they have
their main residence and they put one
person down in one of those properties
and one person RAM in their holiday home
they do that for electoral purposes
because they think that it ties up with
council tax and they benefit from a 25%
discount on both of those properties
rather than paying the full whack on one
of them and a holiday home right on the
other so they say quite a significant
amount of money across to authorities by
doing that will this help to control of
that Thank You councillor
may I ask Andrew woke up to see if
there's any way we can tie up that the
fact that people are registered in two
different places okay thank you chair
and yes clips off you these are the
types
we are targeting so as part of our
discount review we take all our records
compare them to financial credit records
we also compare them to other
authorities records and these are the
discrepancies that we then work through
so for last year we compared 9000
records
1700 came up as discrepancies there the
1700s with a contact and from that I
think it was just under two hundred and
fifty were removed so we do liaise with
other authorities we will question the
counts taxpayer on to determine their
main residence and we will determine
their main residence so we do have
classic cases where perhaps somebody has
a property in London where they work in
the week that they return a weekend and
they may argue London is their main home
we were like you actually the family
home but the weekend is the main home
when we won't for that discount so they
are the type of cases we are looking to
target thank you Andrew does anyone else
have any comment on on this it seems
quite a sensible thing thing to do
obviously we we're doing everything we
can to ensure that we have up-to-date
information and that we do get people to
respond timely with when the
circumstance has changed but this is
small amount of penalty and it's not not
a significant amount I think will help
in improving the process Katla Parker I
think sure I'm just looking at the
policy number five exceptions just
something that we ought to be aware of
so I'd just be interested know how they
how the practicalities of implementing a
fine would work so if we identify that
you know somebody might be receiving a
fine and yet they fall into one of these
exceptions category sister seems to have
the potential to be you know
quite a bureaucratic exercise so you
know we've got the potential clients for
want of a better word who are going to
be sitting worrying about this this fine
I mean how long is this process going to
take have any any idea to identify
whether they fall into these categories
and whether they're exempt or not I
think the first key point in most of
counts fetch records all we have is a
name than address so unless they're in
receipt to some type of benefit or a
discount that identifies them it's a
particular category we just have a name
so we may eventually have a situation
where a penalty is levied because
they've returned any information
requested it would then be if they come
back an appeal through conversations
engagement we then identify it
actually they may meet one of these
exceptions then we would withdraw the
discount but yeah I've ought to be a
protection wise we just have to have a
name and know that they're over 18 so we
could run into some challenges however
talking to authorities that have
implemented this elsewhere they've had
very few challenges and even the
Department of Work and Pensions offer a
sanction that any overpayment I think
over fifty pound
they then charge of penalty so feedback
from elsewhere is it's not in that
labor-intensive
and I think also councillor Parker when
we come onto the next item on the agenda
that that might help with with this
particular issue does anyone else have
anything they wish to ask okay then
we've had the recommendation proposed
and seconded
all those in favor thank you and moving
on now the next item is paper B C a 1927
council tax the Citizens Advice
collection protocol so one of the core
objectives of the shared revenues
partnership is to maximize the
collection of council tax while ensuring
the processes in place are fair and
ethical level of council tax debt is
increasing across the country and this
is described in paragraph 4.2 of the
report charities are warning at these
areas in our rival credit card debts as
their biggest concern moreover there are
also stories in the press about warnings
from charities that heavy-handed
collection tactics are putting severe
pressure on those already in financial
difficulty Citizens Advice reported that
growing numbers of people are turning to
them for help with council tax issues
Citizens Advice together with a Local
Government Association have produced a
good practice protocol for the
collection of council tax arrears the
protocol aims to help councils in
England improve the experience for
residents in arrears whilst also
improving collection of what is owed
this supports the government's desire to
improve the way council tax debtors are
covered in the light of all this the
shared revenues partnership has been
engaging with the Citizens Advice to
review the processes in place but
collection and benchmark these against
the standards set out in the protocol by
working closely together the council its
enforcement agents and Citizens Advice
can improve collection processes with
more early intervention to assist
residents struggling with their council
tax payments to help prevent further
charges alleviate stress and reduce both
collection costs and demand on public
services in the districts this report
proposes that
council adopt this protocol further
information is provided in the report
and Appendix A which contains the good
practice protocol itself so I'd like to
propose the recommendation a paragraph
3.1 of the report that is to approve the
adoption of the Citizens Advice Castle
Tax protocol detailed at Appendix A of
the report and the reason that the
protocol reflects best practice at local
government level and is intended to
facilitate regular liaison with this
council its enforcement agents and
citizens advice on practices and policy
concerning council tax collection in
setting down clear procedures and
keeping these regularly under review all
parties to the protocol can ensure that
arrears are dealt with appropriately
whilst complaints are handled
efficiently may have a second a police
car Osborn any questions or comments
anyone
Kathir Aarthi i'll ask a question so
it's about the in the report it talks
about how nationally the level of
council tax debt is increasing but I
think I'm right in saying that although
the figures are slightly different
year-on-year we have not seen a
significant rise in council tax debt in
recent years have we it hasn't let
Andrew give detail response I don't
believe that has affected us although
universal credit me we may be seeing an
impact of that yeah Thank You Jose
yes it's fair to say we maintained
collection rate it took a dip in 2013
with the introduction of the world fair
reform changes and we moved away from a
hundred percent cap benefit scheme but
we are around sort of in year collection
of 98 point 4 we are facing some
challenges this year because we have
customers that have frequent changes to
their benefit either due to universal
credit or sort of the hours they work
changes and what this is meaning any
change in benefit changes how much
counts textio which means we issue a new
bill and when we issue a new bill we
recalculate installments so we are
seeing that this final quarter compared
to where we were last April there's a
million a million pound more we've got a
clipped so we are doing more activity
time we maintain that rate and obviously
the key thing for us it is to identify
the comp pays from the won't pace so
sort of the protocol is helping us deal
with sort of the current pace and how we
can support them so we're going forward
Thank You Andrea
that's Ravi yeah and another question as
well obviously this and the previous
paper as well because we're in the
shared revenues partnership it is quite
important although we're agreeing this
as a council it's quite important that
everybody else does as well isn't it
otherwise you end up please sort of you
know
from rooms applying to different
authorities being operated by one one
group Andrew yeah I said I think that is
the case but the other authorities so I
think all pretty on board of this other
yes I was wearing miss Suffolk but I
didn't actually Chen agreed as long ago
I was at okay thanks
any other comments anyone
right will you've heard the
recommendation proposed and seconded all
those in favor thank you the next and
last item is BCA 1928 and these are
decisions taken by the chief executive
during the pre-election period under
delegated powers in accordance with part
2 of the Constitution and may ask Castle
Osborne to introduce this Thank You mr.
chairman the chief executive has made a
decision in conjunction with the
chairperson of the council under their
delegated powers whilst the council was
in the pre-election period the
regulatory reform housing assistance in
England and Wales order 2002
gives local authorities the power to
develop their own policy to assist their
residents to maintain and adapt their
homes to ensure that they are safe and
suitable for them to live in the housing
assistance policy has been developed to
allow baver and mid Suffolk district
councils to make best use of their
disabled facilities grant funding this
will enable the councils to meet their
strategic priorities and to work with
health and social care colleagues to
provide better outcomes for residents
the housing assistance policy known as H
ap sets out how Baber
and mid Suffolk District Council's will
offer assistance to disabled residents
to improve accessibility to and
suitability of their accommodation the H
ap allows favor and mid Suffolk councils
to meet the aspirations set out in their
corporate plan and homes and housing
strategy to ensure that everyone has a
suitable home and residents are able to
live as healthy healthfully safely
independently as possible with
sustainable communities the key
objectives of the housing assistance
policy are to ensure residents are able
to live as healthy healthily safely and
independently as possible to help
prevent hospital care home and
residential home admissions to
facilitate the prompt discharge of
residents from hospital to prevent the
need for increased expenditure
we're in the suffix system including
Health and Social Care the main changes
include increase in the ma G's Nam means
tested to 7,500 from the current 5,000
introduction of a 10k discussion a DFG
to top up the 30k mandatory DFG total of
40 K and relocation grant of up to 7500
na means-tested the policy has now been
implemented and will be carefully
monitored to measure the success of
introducing additional options to try
and reduce the DFG underspend Thank You
mr. chair thank you can swim anyone have
any questions on on this sir Karthi the
question on this one as well I'm just
trying to be absolutely clear about what
the chief executive agreed
did he agree the policy or did he agree
the awards because the financial
implications given here are quarterly
figures for awards so I'm presuming to
us just for information only and that
what the chief executive actually
approved was the policy is that right
yes simple answer so just following on
from that it would have been nice if
we've got the policy here proved
attached would have been a nice touch
guess all yeah we can we can forward for
that on Heather no problem
Castle Sonya can I just add to this we
are going out to the the various
partners to sort of advertise the
availability of this grant but we need
to be to it to be taken up and members
play a key role in this you know you're
out there hands-on so if all members can
get out there and be aware of the Vale
ability of this grant that would
unassured increase the take-up of it and
help their residents to live safely and
independently and we certainly need to
report it to to our parish from town
councils so that they can help
disseminate the information as well yeah
if they could include it in their
district council reports I always do in
mind at the Town Council so we could all
do that that would be fantastic
councillor Hathi I'm sure we can all do
that and that's another reason why it
would be nice to have the policy the
chief executive approved that we can
look at you'll get it okay are there any
other questions right
can i yes yeah we will circulate the
policy but as I've identified in my
introduction the three main changes
include and that's really basically what
we're doing but we will get the policy
out okay well cut Osborne has proposed a
recommendation having our services oh so
yeah thank you miss Jenna I'd like to
propose the recommendation outlined in
2.1 of the report and it is for noting
it may have a second council Davis okay
all those in favor
thank you right
concludes the meeting actually the next
meeting is next Thursday 5:30 where
we'll be taking a first look at the
draft budget and see you all then thank
you everyone thank you